masks are the first line of defense
against the coronavirus
protecting both the wearers and those
around them from infectious aerosols and
droplets
but some doubt that masks actually
protect against covert 19.
with protests across the globe against
restrictions including right here in
germany
what does the latest research tell us
about how the disease is spread
do masks help prevent new infections
what about social distancing
is it safe to travel or exercise open
questions that need answers
as we continue to navigate life in the
pandemic
[Music]
well the study by berlin charity
hospital has found the risk of catching
the coronavirus from contaminated
surfaces
is lower than thought that's the good
news the bad news is
the risk from droplets and aerosols is
greater than previously thought
that means talking singing coughing or
sneezing can spread the virus
enclosed spaces with reduced air
circulation also pose a risk
close proximity indoors with poor
ventilation
and physical exertion these are factors
that help encourage infection
with sars cov2
everything indoors where there's little
fresh air to start with obviously one
has to be very careful about aerosol
transfer
this first became apparent through
infections in choirs
counter tobias broman was rehearsing
with 80 singers in the rehearsal room of
berlin cathedral on march the 9th
their chairs were distributed throughout
the 120 square meter room
five days after the rehearsal 60 members
of the choir were sick
people were infected all over the room
[Music]
because droplet infection over such long
distances is almost impossible
scientists suspected aerosols were
responsible for transmission
aerosols are tiny particles like fine
dust
virus particles can attach themselves to
the aerosols
and spread infection scientists are now
certain that these are the main
infection route indoors
aerosols occur wherever liquids are
finally atomized
this can happen for example on people's
vocal folds when they're speaking or
singing
while larger droplets can't travel far
because they fall to the ground
smaller aerosols are lighter and float
in the air for several hours indoors
spreading all over that's why
ventilation is so important
constant ventilation is best rooms
should be ventilated every 20 minutes
ideally ensuring cross ventilation
a fan can also convey stale air outside
each person has i'm personally very
careful whenever i'm indoors
if there's no fresh air supply i'm very
careful and if there's something else
like an air conditioner blowing the air
around
then i'm especially careful
the air is circulated like that then i
wouldn't stay in that environment very
long
outside aerosols are harmless the tiny
particles are diluted so quickly in the
fresh air that they're not dangerous
because infection requires a certain
quantity of viral droplets
also ultraviolet light renders the
aerosols harmless
the best thing to do is to meet people
outside
a quiet family gathering in the
countryside is practically the best
solution
where you can also observe social
distancing
the worst situation is in a closed room
with hundreds of people partying for 10
hours
drunk and shouting that's naturally a
horror situation when it comes to the
transmission of the novel coronavirus
the berlin cathedral choir has responded
to the danger of indoors
their rehearsals now take place outside
the cathedral
much to the delight of passers-by
[Music]
well william schaffner works in
preventive medicine and infectious
diseases
just how infectious is the coronavirus
when
airborne according to the latest
research
well it certainly can be transmitted via
the airborne
route at some distance we still think
most of the infections
are transmitted indoors within six feet
but there's no doubt now those airborne
particles can travel
more widely at a greater distance
particularly if you have someone who is
a
super spreader and is shedding large
amounts
of virus so both close in and
farther out contribute to transmission
this is a very
contagious virus who in this case is a
super spreader so someone who's not
wearing a mask
oh certainly someone who's not wearing a
mask
masks are very effective in
in blocking transmission out and of
course that's why the recommendation is
here in the united states at least that
all of us should be wearing
masks whenever we're around other people
what would you say to the guys at my gym
who refuse to wear a mask some of my
colleagues even and people out there who
just say
they have a right not to wear a mask
well it's very difficult to persuade
people
who are very fixed in their beliefs but
it's not a matter of
right right depends only on your
behavior
but this is a contagious virus what you
do
actually affects others not wearing a
mask
that's like driving your car when the
light is red
you endanger others as well as yourself
what about something like air
conditioning or ventilation
uh systems i know quite a lot of people
are worried about that the the famous
berlin club bear khan has partly
reopened with
fans installed on the dance floor and in
the toilets to prevent the spread of
aerosols and allow people to party but
how effective are measures like that
well we think that air conditioning
which brings
new air in and gets some air out
and moves air around actually dilutes
the virus
so most of us think that air
conditioning is beneficial
it's still a matter of debate and
regular fans
the the salzburg festival has told
classical music lovers for example to
keep their fans folded
and endure the heat saying fanning could
spread infectious aerosols
instead of allowing them to be sucked up
by the air conditioning
yeah you see there are two ways to look
at the fan
first of all does it spread the virus
potentially yes but does it also dilute
the virus and we think the answer to
that is yes
so air movement akin to what it is
outside
most of us think is a good thing things
will get more difficult in the winter
when we have to keep our windows
closed oh yeah yeah i haven't even got
to that yet i
did want to ask you what's going to
happen because we're talking about
you know doing so much outdoors what
happens when winter comes
well when winter comes we're going to
have two problems
not only covet but influenza our old
friend will visit us
so here in the united states we're
recommending everyone older than six
months of age
be vaccinated against influenza it's not
a perfect vaccine
but it still can prevent many influenza
infections
personal protection that's good and it
will take some of the strain
off the health care system the hospitals
emergency rooms
doctors offices so we're urging everyone
to get vaccinated against flu
this year how worried are you about the
second wave that is
currently sweeping parts of the world
yeah i'm worried about it seriously
worried here in the united states says
everyone knows we're not doing a good
job
in controlling this virus we're still in
the first wave
and it could get worse this winter
so we need a a national plan
which is not yet forthcoming so we're
struggling here
covet will be with us it will not
disappear
no no it doesn't sound like it at all
william um one last question
a british study has found singing is no
more of a covet 19 risk than talking
it says volume is the most important
risk factor
that's the university of bristol the
researchers there found that
aerosol mass produced rose steeply
with an increase in volume of singing or
speaking by as much as 20 to 30 percent
or 30 times rather
um can you comment on that
yeah i'm a little dubious about that
study
singing involves more volume
so we will spread the virus more with
singing
i think i've never been to a quiet
concert that's
for sure william looking ahead is there
anything
positive you can leave us with
we're working on vaccines everybody
around the world is working on vaccines
we have vaccines now
in final stage clinical trials we hope
my fingers across that they will work
and then we can start distributing this
vaccine
around the world my fingers are also
across william schaffner thank you very
much for joining us there from nashville
dunk derek williams turn
now to answer your questions on the
coronavirus our science correspondent
has been
holed up in his home office since the
beginning of the crisis
can certain pre-existing conditions
cause some people to get sicker than
others
i was kind of amazed when someone
pointed out that i haven't answered this
really pretty basic question in the five
months i've been doing this so
no time like the present um a range of
underlying medical conditions what are
known as as comorbidities
are associated with more severe outcomes
if you contract
covet 19. um there's a long list of
conditions
that that might be linked to it as well
but the evidence is pretty clear
that people are in particular danger who
have a chronic heart
respiratory or kidney disease diabetes
cancer sickle cell disease
as well as patients who are
immunocompromised
or obese um because many patients have
more than one of those co-morbidities
it's proven
pretty difficult to rank them but a
widely accepted study from june
estimates that nearly one in five people
worldwide
is at increased risk due to at least one
comorbidity and and one in 20
is at high risk those people in
particular should pay
close attention to social distancing
measures in daily interactions
they should wear face coverings they
should wash their hands often
and not break off their treatment plan
without talking to their doctor
and finally they should continue to get
as much
safe physical activity as possible
you